aujourd'hui on a 6 7 millions de
québécois qui ont accès groupe de
médecine de famille ces trois cent mille
de plus que parce que les libéraux nous
avait laissé françois legault at il
raison
[Musique]
oui mais il ne dit pas tout
quand la cac est arrivé au pouvoir 6
millions 400 mille québécois avaient
accès à un médecin de famille la barre
des 6 millions 600 mille a été franchie
à la fin 2020 puis ça redescendu en juin
cette année on était pratiquement au
même point qu'en 2018 et puis d'un seul
coup au mode où près de 300 mille
personnes ont été inscrites un groupe de
médecine familiale selon le dernier
bilan ces six millions six cent
cinquante huit mille québécois qui ont
accès à un médecin de famille ou à un
gmf la distinction est importante
la dernière vague d'inscriptions c'est
le résultat d'une entente conclue entre
le gouvernement et les omnipraticiens le
printemps dernier les patients concernés
n'ont pas de médecin de famille attitré
mais on leur promet qu'ils pourront voir
un médecin ou un autre professionnel de
la santé dans le gmf où ils sont
inscrits en ce moment 80 % de la
population a accès à un médecin de
famille ou un gmf la cac est donc bien
loin d'avoir rempli sa promesse de 2018
au cours des quatre prochaines années
tous les québécois pourront avoir accès
à leur médecin de famille ou une
infirmière à l'intérieur de trente six
ans si de côté plus de québécois on est
en famille la liste d'attentes du
guichet d'accès a pratiquement doublé
pendant le mandat de la cac pour
atteindre 8 134 mille personnes
comment est ce possible parce que des
gens qui n'ont pas de médecin ou qui ont
perdu leurs médecins continuent de
s'inscrire il y à davantage de nouvelles
inscriptions que de nouvelles places qui
sont offertes